one of the best evaluators of talent
joining us right here on the rich eisen
show our buddy todd mcshea back here how
are you todd
i'm great rich how are you doing i am
doing well so what did you see
last night out of joe burrow let's just
get right into the evaluation
of him through two weeks now
i just think he's tough as nails i
really do i i just
i love watching joe burrow in the pocket
and you know
they don't get the win and he's
struggling but the fact that he
he's transferred what he did in his last
year at lsu
to his rookie year in the nfl with an
offensive line that's kind of up and
down
and the ability to he just doesn't
he doesn't worry about the pressure he
feels it he's aware of it
but he knows like when the outside
pressure's coming he
just calmly climbs and when it's coming
from the inside he slides right or left
and
and if you're watching all the great
quarterbacks in the nfl whether it's
it's aaron rodgers or
drew brees obviously you know
peyton manning going back to his
inability to run but ability to move
inside the pocket tom brady the same
thing
the great ones are are masters
working inside the pocket and that's
that's what he does so well
and and going back to the toughest nails
i mean you talked about the play where
the strip sack yep for miles garrett the
other guy
i don't even remember who it was but the
other guy nailed him
i mean he just rocked him and that's
what you saw
time after time from him playing against
you know
fcc talon and those great defensive
linemen
he gets knocked down and so he doesn't
like peel himself
off up off the ground he just pops up
and it's like next play and he's always
been like that and i've always respected
that about his game
it probably has something to do with the
fact that his dad is a coach his
brothers were linebackers and safeties
in nebraska like
he comes from a family of football and
he's used to just like
getting knocked out and having to jump
right back up well i guess and
and i get the good news is for
cincinnati even though
owen ii is you know the same old bengals
that gets thrown around quite a bit as
we saw
with uh a game tying field goal uh that
should have been an easy chip shot
no good because their kicker cramps as
he attempts to swing his leg through
like what happened in week
does not apply to the choice of joe
burrow like like you could see
right now two games in not eight
quarters and five days in
that he that this was it this is the
right first overall selection
right yeah there's no question you can
un fortunately and unfortunately in some
cases
you can't get the full picture but you
get a really good sense from about
three four games into the rookie season
of how they're handling it
what's going on the guys respecting them
around them and how
like how they're able to pick up the
offense and
understand how things are changing on
the defensive side and
i just don't have any worries about them
i really don't like
they need to get better on the offensive
line they need to get more consistent on
the defensive side and some more talent
and influx there but i have no concern
when it comes to what's going on at the
quarterback position for the bengals
for the next several years and and i i
think he's going to elevate everyone
around him and that's what you expect to
get when you
use the number one overall pick on on a
quarterback and we were discussing this
with your
uh compatriot daniel jeremiah last week
about
what does make a successful nfl
quarterback who's been drafted or
or rated high or drafted in the first
two three rounds
is that you know is it environment
or is it just somebody who could just
take a team and elevate it himself
regardless of who the coach is or
revolving doors and
and i'm wondering where you stand on
that subject because obviously you've
got
darnold and josh allen from this draft
that we're still
talking about we had baker last night
from this draft
rich i i think honestly not to cut you
off i i think
the more i'm the more i'm involved in
the more i've been around this and
evaluating players i i want to believe
that the environment has to be right and
all those sorts of things
but if you're if you're using a number
one overall pick
if you're using a first round pick
you're drafting a guy that you
have to believe is going to kind of
transcend everything else he's going to
bring the rest of your organization
up to speed like andrew luck did prior
to the injury
situations like that was an awful roster
and look what he did with that
look what tom brady did with an offense
it has rare that rarely had
elite players on that side of the ball
you know i mean
joe burrow comes in you see it right
away kyler murray goes into arizona it's
different
daniel jones goes to the giants
and he's a good player and there's
there's hope and you've got
arguably the best back in the nfl behind
him in saquon barkley
but you know already that you have to
have a lot of things around him
to be successful right i mean i think
it's very obvious
and you can go down the list like baker
you have to have a lot of things around
them
sam i think can kind of transcend things
with with the jets
but he needs a little bit more josh
allen you have to have everything around
him like he has with the bills like
there are just certain guys lamar
jackson and i didn't see it at the time
and i'll be the first to admit it i had
him
fifth as on the quarterbacks that year
behind baker mayfield
uh sorry sam darnold josh allen josh
rosen
um yeah and baker mayfield and then uh
lamar was fifth on my list that year but
lamar
they've they've transitioned the offense
to him
but he's capable of taking over the
organization and being that guy so
if you're using the number one overall
pick you're expecting to get that
whether you get it or not it really
decides what's going to happen with your
future for the next five six years
uh and in terms of you know todd um
let's
let's stick on darnold for a second here
um
you know at least burrow does have i
mean you got tyler boyd you got
um uh aj green obviously
joe mixon so at least he does have some
weaponry although maybe not the
protection up front
and sam donald's got uh frank gore he's
turning around to frank gore and handing
to frank gore in 2020 to start a game
against the san francisco 49ers
and frank may be the most decorated
dependable offensive weapon he's got
and this is year three so you say he can
transcend the jets he's going to have to
i mean right i mean this is this is it
what what's where do you stand on sam
darnold for the jets gonna have to make
a decision
about picking up a fifth year on yeah i
mean obviously
frank frank was not the he was not the
primary
you know when you and and this is before
joe douglas the gm
they made the decision to pay this
amount of money to
to levion bell and and i guess
understandably maybe whatever you think
of it and he was
from a talent standpoint unquestionably
was deserving of a lot of money but i
always have a hard time
when when organizations spend that kind
of money on that position
because of exactly what has happened
here and a lot of other
places in the league so now yeah you
look in the backfield you have frank
franco or you got a rookie
uh la michael p ryan who's uh you know
he's the same thing
as frank gore he's a kind of a pounder
but he's just not nearly as talented and
obviously not nearly as
decorated so now it turns to sam
and you look like i just looked at their
they've got so many issues in terms of
weapons around sam
moving forward and they're trying so
hard obviously
they brought in mckay beckton at left
tackle their
first break in the in this fast draft
you get alex lewis they brought in
um you know they really spent a lot of
this off season trying to upgrade their
offensive line to protect sam
but at tight end you don't see a huge
difference maker in my opinion
and at wide receiver you got a bunch of
you know guys that are solid but no one
no one is scaring you defensively so
that allows you defensively to come up
and
and and throw games at sam to take away
the run and really
press and get physical and i think
that's that's the issue that the jets
have right now but
i i would go to war with sam darnold
i would put him in the top six or seven
quarterbacks in the league in terms of
guys that i believe in
moving forward for the next few years i
really believe that he's a special
talent
they just need some time to get the guys
around them well i mean and uh
if time unfolds in the manner in which
we saw in week one and i know this is a
total knee-jerk reaction but when you
look at the roster
you see what you see i'm going to ask
you i'm going to front load you
way in advance the million-dollar
question
if the jets have a chance at trevor
lawrence
do you turn sam darnold into the josh
rosen of this equation
you don't you don't really do that no no
no no i don't and and that would
it would be one of those i don't know
few
few situations in in terms of coming up
in this trap i mean
i would sit there you know sit there one
and get a monster deal
i mean that's what you do if you're if
you're joe and you're making that
decision
it's like and listen they're not going
to be picking number one i really don't
believe that's the case but
in your hypothetical if they're picking
at number one i think you sit there and
you get one of the biggest deals that
has
ever been brokered for a number one
overall pick in the history of the nfl
draft
i would argue probably the biggest for
trevor lawrence
so i you're going to wind up with so
many ones
you're going to wind up with at least
two ones
multiple twos and probably two or three
other picks and you can name your price
because they're going to be three or
four
organizations that are bidding against
each other to go up and get
what i think is a generational talent in
trevor lawrence coming out of clemson
and
for me that and now you add in all the
other first round picks i think they got
they have an additional one and a two i
believe in the next two
in the next two years so yeah the jets
would be in in great shape but i
again i i do not foresee that being the
situation well i'm asking it for because
there's already jet fans that are
thinking about it because just watching
that week one it just looks so desolate
and i know
that there's still a lot of football
left to be played but i love the jets
fans
seriously it's one game i mean yeah i
guess
i guess they've earned it over time but
it's one game okay one game it's okay
todd mcshea here on the rich eisen show
and we've been going back and forth
about
uh what type of quarterback these young
quarterbacks like josh allen and baker
mayfield they do need to have these
pieces around them for them to be
successful
um baker's had a bigger bunch of churn
at at coaching
uh obviously four head coaches in his
first three years now
uh what type of co and then there's some
like you think joe burrow or lamar
jackson
they could just uh succeed um
right from the get-go and lift which
quarterback is tua
do you think i'm interested to see the
health
i i cuz based off of
just watching to a healthy yep versus
joe burrow and
you have to look at the the two-year
evaluation
of these you guys and and the i think
joe burrow
the improvement from year one to year
two as a starter at lsu is the greatest
improvement i've ever seen from any
quarterback in the history of college
football leading up to the draft
in 20 years of doing this i've never
seen anything like it
i'm talking a fifth sixth round grade
kind of wrote him off he's kind
he's you know he's a game manager and
just trying to get one year in as a
starter after transferring behind all
those guys at ohio state
and then all of a sudden he becomes
joe burrow like this guy so but
when you look at the two years in when
tua was healthy
and granted tua had uh better weapons
around him
but i thought two of hunger braille was
was the better quarterback over the two
years
and had i had like if you prom i said it
before if you promised me
10 years of health with the two i would
take
two over joe at number one overall this
past year and maybe i would have been
wrong
but um but i think the big thing for for
tua
is getting back healthy getting some
people around him but but just having
confidence in
his body and what he can do and knowing
his limitations that's going to be the
biggest key for him
so what do you think miami taking on the
bills uh josh allen's looking really
terrific
um he he does appear to be you know
um budding that's no question about that
and if the bills go and give miami a bit
of a beatdown
uh as some people think will happen
what do you think brian flores is going
to think about in a short week prior to
week three
um against uh jacksonville between the
dolphins do you think that's where you
insert tool what is your thought
on when we might see tua this year yeah
the one thing and brian first of all i
think
just to say this i think with brian in
their front office i think this is the
best
run dolphins organization that i've seen
probably in a decade
i i really think that and probably more
but i'm just
in the top of my head i i think they
have the right
people in place in terms of leadership
from a personnel standpoint and a
coaching standpoint
okay i don't think i think they realize
that they have time and they're this is
not a race
it's it really is not a sprint they've
got to
make sure that they get it right for
true in the long term because that's
their
their ticket to success for the long
term so
what i don't know is what they really
know
behind the scenes in terms of his health
and where they think he is and
is he strong enough to withstand the you
know
three quarters of an nfl season or a
half of an nfl season whatever it is
but i think it's inevitable that we're
going to see tua
and it's probably sooner than than later
but i also think that they didn't want
to
throw him in there knowing that they
have some deficiencies and knowing
that you know his body type and the fact
that he has had injuries basically every
year of his career going back to high
school
they just want to protect him and they
want to do the right thing and make sure
that they're in the right position to
to take care of their investment and
ultimately when he gets on the field if
he is right
physically i think he has a chance to be
one of the stars in this league i really
really believe that todd mcshay here on
the rich eisen show before
um before we we hang up
first time you and i have spoken um
since the draft which you missed
because of covet 19 what was that i i'm
so
sorry you know i know what the draft
means to you and
how you build to it and then for you not
to
be able to be there for you know espn
and
for all you know it was a it was a
combined broadcast
uh with nfl network and for the nfl for
you not to be there it had to be
absolutely crushing i am so sorry you
went through that
but is there anything you want of course
is there anything you want to tell
people about
having it or and going through it or is
there anything
i'd love to give you the floor if if you
want to take it todd yeah
i haven't thought about this i didn't
know we would go here uh i'm sorry to do
that todd no
no no no it's all good it's all good
because it's important that's what i
figured you know i
would i know i didn't ask you beforehand
either but
yeah no worries i i was um my dr
mitchell who
i've come to love who guided me through
it she um
she she said like bluntly like
you have a mild taste and i remember
looking at her and being like
wow yeah i can't imagine
people that have anything worse than
this i would
i would go to take a nap and try to like
you know text a producer be like i'm
going to try to be on a little bit and
then wake up 13 hours later
and i i didn't know if it was 7 at night
or four in the morning like i i just
didn't know where i was it was dark my
thank thank goodness my wife took my our
children
and and one away on uh in early
april and and got got away just because
she was worried
and uh so i was just sitting at home
trying to battle through it and then
finally just it took over me and so the
point is this i
for anyone who doesn't think it's that
severe
or you know it's it's made up or all
these other things that i hear
it is real and it's scary and to know
that there are people who had it a lot
worse than me
i just i i can't imagine what they went
through because it was a really dark
place
um but i also i'll say this i i've never
felt more like love and appreciation and
more i don't know like team
whatever environment than i that i did
during
those few weeks from everyone that i
worked with at espn it
it was unbelievable the support i got
and it was
to i couldn't watch the draft even
though i was healthy enough to watch it
i couldn't watch it until i was over
because i
just i couldn't stomach it but um but
when it was over i watched it i was so
proud of
of everything that that espn and nfl
network did and
and i appreciated so much the support i
got it honestly it really helped me
through it
knowing that everyone was like don't
worry about work like get over it
just just get healthy and it meant a lot
to me it is just one draft todd and now
you sound great and
don't worry you'll be there in 2021 when
the jets are on the clock and have a
decision whether to take trevor lawrence
or trade everybody so
and i'll still be dealing
oh you'll have a green split screen when
that happens i'll tell you that
that's for sure that's for sure and he's
going to have all the i want to focus on
like all the good like chase young has
the second half cj henderson for
jacksonville
antoine woodenfield junior for the bus
he was great queen has these tackles
all these great rookies i love it we're
focused on the jets i got it well no no
it's okay
we've got more time i'll have you back
on any time todd you're the best thanks
for the time really appreciate it
all right my man you got it you got it
that's uh todd mcshea of espn right here
on the rich eisen show the best
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here